[Music]
hello everybody
and welcome back to
three
scary
this is rojo
a spanish horror experience
does it want me to play with the
controller a play i don't have a mouse
at all
i hit a and it went play so let's find
out what the
spanish horror is all about your friend
has been missing for days the only clue
she has left you is a note in a room
with an address
calais de salamanca
it's been a while since my spanish
classes in uh high school
uh
right click look at detail
you're right about that
am i supposed to look at the detail
am i supposed to see something in these
pictures
i see that squidward painting you know
the one
you know the one
is this gonna block me i couldn't
possibly there's no way
i would
what's under here
hello
oh
ding dong
[Music]
okay
let me look at the detail hmm
am i visiting my grandmother
who's very religious hello
uh
sure
okay since i started my crusade i have
progressed a lot grandma
you went on a crusade
i no longer feel sorry not afraid at
last i have understood that the only way
to return spain to its greatness is by
understanding the
rotten interior of the blasphemers who
destroy it
well grandma
i know how much you love to rant um
i got
oh
i like the way the flashlight moves but
also uh oh okay
hello grandma are you going oh [ __ ] are
you going to take over the government
again
you know we talked about this
hi
that's nothing it's nothing
that's an old stove uh
oh hello
buy insecticide
uh find something that cleans blood
stains scissor knife towels bleach
eggs well you got all the essentials
then
okay
[Music]
gross
okay
um grandma
can't be open for this side you know
what i'm actually grateful for that
wherever the blood leads is usually not
a good place
so
did she read one fortune cookie and then
decided this is a sign
it's time to take over spain
hello i need a key of course i do
of course i do
i need a key
grandma
grandma you in that tub
oh
i thought that was a baby crying that
was me winding the thing hi jesus
um i don't want to see what's behind
this curtain for multiple reasons there
could be nothing good behind here
peekaboo is that sand or is that like an
anti-slip mat i'm gonna assume that's
sand actually i'm not gonna assume that
sand that's probably grandma's dead skin
cells
oh roach okay
for the insecticide hi
lately i feel different stronger wiser
more convinced than ever of my crusade i
no longer need those devil pills ah
grandma
we need to have a talk
i need a key did
was there a key in this room
no keys
that i can see
also i don't know why you're chugging
pills when you take a bath
okay we're good
um no key that i see
must have been
in somewhere else oh i did i guess i
didn't try that door there
oh it opens
good good good good
hello
these blasphemers scream like pigs i
have to prepare a more discreet place
for my investigations missed
generalissimo i wish you were here to
see it
you would be proud
okay um there must be a key here
somewhere i just don't know where
okay key uh spoon uh knife uh fork um
knife
no key key
[Music]
key
who's right there in front of me
okay i got a key i don't know what it's
to but i have it
hello
nope not that one of course not
that one
yay grandma
[Music]
are there scratches on the wall grandma
oh no that's just the wrinkling of the
wallpaper grandma
hi
jesus you okay
[Music]
left click to read clue
jesus keeps the key of hope the heart of
jesus belongs to god and only if we are
able to see it will we be able to reach
the truth
okay
so the heart of jesus ah there's nothing
all right
so
uh-huh there is nothing you're right
about that
hi
nothing
okay
oh good
grandma grandma please don't jump out at
me
grandma please don't jump out at me i
cannot overstate this enough
call the police we don't know we need
that yet we don't know about that yet
we don't know that
let's not panic here
okay
lovely channel
maybe my favorite generalissimo those
dogs are going to get you out of the
valley they do not know what they do
they are going to unleash hell on earth
and that hell it will be me
oh god oh god
oh
what am i looking at what am i looking
at oh it's a funeral
okay well that's more normal than i
thought it would be
okay
all right okay
oh
the heart of jesus
wow raw steaks for dinner and you sat
the table for multiple people
ah
well that's handy
it seems that the brain is the key of
the abnormal behavior of the enemies of
fatherland the other organs do not seem
to be related to the deviation they are
suffering from the path of god it will
be necessary to take advantage
yeah those pesky brains and all their
free will and nonsense
gotta get rid of those
we can't be having that i'm gonna go to
the last room i got the key for
that light was always on right that
light was always ominously bright and on
right
definitely grandma
okay
grandma
left click to play now why would i do
that
why would i do all these things that you
were telling me to do i don't know
ignorant minds like i could read it
ignorant minds like an empty bookshelf
that's what separates the sheep from my
vision my crusade for the redemption of
spain
interesting
i have to go find a bookshelf first i
gotta do a little piano
[Music]
nice
those are unrelated it's coincidence
it's coincidence
perfectly fine
nothing to worry about here
so where was there a bookshelf
who had a bookshelf
not here
you're not a bookshelf
you are a bookshelf
ah
god damn i'm strong okay that's bad
man i should try to call the police but
i don't think it'll do any good oh hi
grandma you got swole
[Music]
grandma
you uh
oh
that's a let me investigate hmm
yep
that's [ __ ] up
that is [ __ ] up grandma you uh busy
working
on stuff and things
grandma oh yeah you gotta
this is your workout room it's to study
anatomy and know what muscles you're
working at any proper time i get that
thoroughness
oh yes so you always know you're
being watched you can't ever get lazy
huh
gotta
solder things
oh no
oh
hate that
hello
okay sure
hi
yep
jingle jangle
yep totally fine
ah oh
uh huh that's a normal door
that's fine
just four notes of the glorious melody
of the fatherland are enough to unblock
the truth
uh
aha
i'm gonna go now i don't know why i'm
still here
i should leave
and never come back
now would be when i call the police
how i suspected this
where was that piano was it over here i
think it was over here
hello
[Music]
what door oh that door okay i don't know
why i'd want to do that
i don't know why i feel the need to go
deeper
okay grandma
grandmama grandmama
i'm
here to help question mark
graham
mama what's that
it's just a rope there
whoa hi grandma grandma no grandma you
don't want to do this grandma
grandma grandma don't do this
grab
good thing there's a perfectly
convenient circle for me to go around oh
that's not
the right timing
you fool you fool
oh
oh why is it locked why is that locked
why would that be locked oh i should
have left oh oh god oh god oh no i'm
boned
hey i'll juke you
i should have just left
oh
thank you
thank you for that
okay here we go three two one a peekaboo
oh goodbye
[Music]
so if my guesstimation is correct then
yeah that'll be locked but i could go
around you here
come at me come at me grandma
grandma
are you fool
you fool
you've fallen right into my trap
and now i will know the truth
i will know the truth oh grandma oh this
is not what i expected
um i should go i have to leave
[Music]
i have important business that i forgot
that i needed to attend to thank you for
uh letting me stop by always a delight
when i see you grandma anyway smooches
can i have 20 rk i'm out the door thank
you
okay bye
where do i go oh this way
am i free
that wasn't bad
i'm not gonna lie i was uh pretty tense
the whole time because i always expect
something to happen earlier in there
just this uh black shadowy mass that
replaced my grandma but very good i
liked that a lot i think it was very
good just like world building wise it's
pretty nice moving on
this is game
found my oh my god oh
wow this is fun
[Music]
uh
red
oh no what did i choose what did i
choose what did i choose what did i
choose
oh that was exit
oh
ah
it's like a main man i see all right
okay
seems like i'm waking up i must have
fallen asleep
yeah i must have i should go to bed yeah
i should
all this seems perfectly normal
um
okay
all right you know it's amazing how when
i see even if it's the basic premise of
like waking up in a house when the house
looks different
meaning like it's not made from
community assets or like a prefab house
or it's got a little style to it it's
amazing how much
more unsettling it feels because it's
unfamiliar
hello
oh what a beautiful scene
this is not my bed that's not my bed i
should know better that's not my bed
oh lights
we have lights oh
what was that
is that just me and my footsteps echoing
kind of funny
hello is this my bed
no
is this my bed
maybe
bed
is there someone at the door is there
someone in my house
hello
they can't be back home yet they would
have called first who
who
who are we talking about here
who we talked about
hello
oh oh i didn't know
oh no
who can play that game [ __ ]
what is going on
yeah i don't know what's going on i need
to find my flashlight yeah
i know i left it somewhere in the
kitchen yeah sure okay this is why
everyone should have a flashlight on
them at all times which we do with our
phones
what a powerful one like a hundred
thousand lumen one is that it is that is
that i see some kind of
dick like object in front of me
a wine bottle
somewhere in the kitchen
you said so
i don't know
oh there
ah
[Applause]
why what are you saying to me ooh
what is this can i have that and
apparently not okay can't have that
well i don't know what that's about but
i gotta get to the bottom of this
mystery here
oh
uh
[Music]
can you stop by my place
can you come here
what
cassie is that you what do you mean did
i check those rooms there was no one
there
cassie why is the door locked now cassie
there's a key
i need to get the keys from the bedroom
i saw a key on the kitchen but it's in
the bedroom
apparently don't know why
why would you do this
i'll kill you
what what'd you say
that's a rumble
cassie
don't mind my screaming
everything's fine
probably
hello
what am i looking at
what am i looking at what am i looking
at cassie
help i don't know if i can seems to be a
demon demon problem
i'm not uh i'm not uh i'm not educated
in such matters
i'll leave that to the experts
um
hello
there's another
police car oh
[Applause]
is going whoa what is going on
i should check electrical breaker box in
the garage
oh should i
oh is that what i should do
sure
hi
any demons in here
come out and say
where's the breaker
everything looks fine strange
how many times have i told the
neighborhood kids
not to play with lightning hello
oh that's not good
that's not good
[Music]
huh
[Applause]
oh hi oh okay oh hi hello
howdy neighbor
what
what is happening
what does this have to do with the game
this is not a test nationwide state of
emergency please stand by for further
instructions this is not a test
several recordings
[Music]
i don't know if i have shelter
this message will be repeated in 10
seconds
oh what why who's that oh hi that's okay
i'm dead now
oh
[Music]
oh my god here i go
uh
what this was called game found a video
game was discovered on dark alley street
in spooky town the victims have not yet
been recognized but based on the game's
extremely poor condition and scratches
on the cover it seems that the victim
was thrown away like an old worn sweater
and unfulfilled dreams according to
investigators the developer is suspected
of being involved and may possibly be a
key suspect for leaving the game and
attempting to destroy evidence
what
i don't know i don't know but that was
pretty cool for what it was whatever it
was whatever i saw that happened in
front of me
that was pretty cool
moving on i guess
this is within yourself it's a game
that's inspired by the joy of creation
which is a game that i have not thought
about in a while but was a very good
five nights at freddy's fan game
and this is supposed to be a short
experience related to that or something
like that or inspired by that or
something like that oh i didn't mean to
do that
i guess i'm going now
a note of memory loss deep below
send it back and he'll awake
who
or last here for your eternity
oh it's a screen i thought it was just
like
okay well
that's uh concerning
um
okay
i don't know what i'm doing there's a
trash cans i guess but
where am i
oh
am i supposed to go down this all right
first all right here we go
no all right fine
that's a little weird
oh hello
uh there's nothing here
okay
oh okay i thought i would no that's
right
um
a note of memory oh
a note of memory
well let's wake this [ __ ] up
you've been napping too long pal you
gotta go down in the below
hi-yah
i did it
i regret doing it
go back why
why would i do that
oh my oh i should go back hey
i'm going back i'm going back now
i'm right back
no
i gotta go back in
i gotta go back
i gotta go back apparently
oh no a room of colors and gates
blocks you from changing your fate
don't turn your back or go insane
for he will strike when you look away
well that doesn't rhyme okay
hey what's up
hey how you doing
where is you i kinda assume the whole
he's only gonna move when i look thing
that was in security breach okay so
we've got colors it's uh red green blue
so let's get the reds first one
two three three
greens
one two
two three two blues one two three four
five five
so three two five
one three two five one okay got it three
two five one
bam
oh i should have been looking ahead
oh god
oh
oh hold on i'm not looking
i would never look
i know look
hey what's up belle hey how you doing
hey come on
i just need you to get out of the
doorway
that's a good boy
nice ass two pink dots there
[Music]
three pink dots here
okay
and a quick d four or five
five five pink dots
i've got it
i need to get you over here so i can
look at you
while i'm punching in the codes
[Music]
okay that's close enough buddy that's
close enough okay what are we looking at
okay it was uh blue there were five red
there were three two so five five three
two i think
five
oh god
uh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ]
okay you come over here then huh
you
uh
oh ah there we go
that should be good enough
i think there were five weren't there
five five three two that sounds about
right five five
three
three three two
no
no was it five
five six three two
what
there are five
are there five
five one two three
four five they're five
two three four five six
six
six five three
three two
there we go i was mistaken on the
numbering
there wouldn't happen to be another one
of you over there with there
is this the one
good just the one just the one just the
one
hey good oh good adore
hey don't do that is there another note
i gotta chuck down i didn't see one
[Music]
okay i guess i just go then
okay
oh
oh that's not good
well that's what you don't want
you don't want that
where'd you go oh where'd you go
where'd you go buddy
buddy pal buddy pal buddy friend pal
buddy
buddy pal friend buddy pal friend friend
friend buddy pal
where'd you go
where'd you go buddy
huh
hello
no
okay i'm confused
all right i guess maybe i go back the
way i came
okay
i don't see a note that i could chuck
down so i guess i just go back
i don't know
oh good oh oh the final stretch
oh good
um
okay uh
well
peek-a-boo peek-a-boo
peek-a-boo peek-a-boo oh you're fast
i don't like that
okay this is a bit of a problem
this is a big bit of a problem
there's a huge bit of a problem okay if
i don't look at those but keep those
over here they're gonna come over to one
side right so i look away from those
hope
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is how we do
this is how we're going to do it
keep coming this way
yeah yeah just like that just like that
okay yeah scoot scooters
scootchams
okay what are we doing with here
i can keep everything except that one in
the corner in view but that's not gonna
do me any good
let me try this
i can't see
you you you you
[Music]
you you oh too close i might be boned i
might be boned
i might be oh you're you're just kind of
come plowing how fast are they when i'm
not looking uh
that one doesn't seem to be moving the
one far left i don't know maybe is maybe
i shouldn't be getting him closer but i
don't know what else to do
hope
okay
gee willikers okay i just gotta make a
break for it they're about as clumped
away as i can get i hate this but i
gotta just go right that's what i gotta
do i just gotta go for it okay okay here
we go here we go here we go here we go
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go here we go here we go here
we go here we go here we go there we go
there we go there we go there we go
oh got too close
oh a little too close there
all right
okay good that didn't go well
please tell me i can just start okay
good
cool
cool all right cool okay
okay cool cool cool
how the hell do i get past those dudes
they just keep coming
oh my god oh no i've backed myself in
i've barked myself in i've johann
sebastian
barked myself in oh god that's too close
it's too close
oh can i slip by there oh can i slip
through that
oh my god oh my god i'm doomed i'm
doomed
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop
oh
[Music]
i made it okay good
i made it unless that's like you're
saying i made that that was pretty good
it's amazing how like a mechanic that
i've seen before is still scary it just
goes to show that like some things when
done well
still scary
[Music]
thank you so much for watching
you don't need to worry
everything is okay
we are always here
watching
you
[Music]